je suis franklin et bagues et je suis né
pour briller je vais beaucoup trop vite
pour vous et je sais que sans gêne plus
d'un et dieu a un projet pour moi
personne ne pas m'arrêter laissez-passer
l'artiste
[Musique]
vous êtes disqualifié pour faux départ
on est tous là pour l'amour du sport ok
on s'y remet les gants sous les monoprix
a tenté encore acheté par le basket
basket c'était jordan 6,91 samedi soir
qu'est-ce que ça pour moi dans mon pote
du adidas dunac c'est quoi j'étais à
faire durer plus longtemps en suspens
c'est quoi son avenir
je sais que tu espérais un gros
équipementiers finaliser très courte
je suis combien sur la liste eh tu n'es
pas sur les listes parce que je suis en
mode vidéo la [ __ ] c'est quoi faire
c'est fini franck cantine chic
nous souffrons et quand tu écris c'est
l'afrique toute entière
l'échappatoire et si c'est le cas le
haut et ont respecté la loi
non tu es là j'ai bien su bien le retour
de franck d'accord écouter on est
content de l'apprendre franklin même si
on n'avait pas posé la question mais là
pour bosser
or la télé le show-business pas
maintenant et pas pour des pauses site
internet de bâle ont trahi pour canal+
mesurait alors j'ai le décodeur ne
t'inquiète pas
alors c'est vrai que c'est une belle
fille miley grave tu comprends pourquoi
je craque et éliminer à fond qu'un façon
c'est toujours de ma faute